how are you feeling tonight I feel
wonderful I feel great you know it's as
I always tell you all it's a state of
grace it's a state of gratitude I am so
thankful to be here I am so thankful to
have my name called as one of the best
now in the world being the best always I
was going to say you know we've been
speaking it for a minute but now that
the masses have come to the party you
know I'm sure it feels very good now you
know we all are still talking about your
legendary Emmy speech we're still
talking when I try to say what's in your
head do you think about that and do you
think about if you have to get up there
again I had no idea how many people
needed to be encouraged I had no idea
how many people needed to be empowered I
had no idea just telling people that
they must they must never ever give up
on themselves I had no idea how much it
would mean I still to this day to this
moment I get messages calls from people
around the world and it's just it's been
amazing and what to do next who knows I
I don't know I'll thank Big Bob Iger for
coming back to Disney what can I say
well you have on Art tonight what is
this art is this hand beaded no shade
it's custom made how about that Jason
rambert I mean Jason is an amazing
stylist turned designer and he and my
daughter Ivy who is with me this evening
who styled me for this she said Jason
design a gown and that's exactly right
behind you right there that's Ivy right
there
to make this because it's I mean up
close it is stunning intricate this is
the kind of work that he put in saying
Miss Ralph you're gonna get nominated
for a Golden Globe and we're working on
it right now and the two of them Jason
and Coco got together and um made the
magic happen
it's beautiful and gorgeous listen we
love you we are so happy for you about
them we let out a collective scream at
the Emmys yes we did if your name's
called tonight I might have to do a
little holy dance now amen amen and I
thank the Hollywood Foreign Press
Association for opening up their hearts
and Minds to understand that diversity
really matters and it really works you
are up against Janelle in the same
category no no no I'm just in the same
category with Janelle there's no
comparison there is no competing I thank
God is that it's that girl in the crown
I'm looking at hey
foreign